peu
[Musique]
petite fille
pour l'année moi j'aime bien
fabien
est ce que ce sont les femmes qui ont
fait la victoire du short ou bien les
fabricants les femmes avant tout et les
fabricants ont suivi facilement les
fabricants ont eu beaucoup de mal à
suivre ils ont été plus de court tout le
monde avait prévu du long pour cet été
ce printemps ce qui était une erreur
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
omar sharif que pensez-vous du short de
la mode du short
moi je trouve ça fantastique
personnellement je trouve surtout que
c'est c'est ce qu'une fille peut mettre
de mieux et je pense que n'importe qui
qui aime beaucoup les femmes aiment bien
les voir en short à moins qu'elle soit
très vilaine je trouve
on dit que par exemple il faut avoir de
très belles jambes pour porter le choc
mais je ne trouve pas tellement il faut
ne pas avoir des jambes affreuse mais je
trouve que très souvent le short les
jambes au fond en font un plus bel effet
je veux dire même si elles sont pas
parfaites en tant qu'avocat que
pensez-vous du short
vous avez eu raison de l'interroger un
homme de loi sur cette très sérieuse
question parce que le short peut poser
des problèmes sur le terrain juridique
une femme portant choc pourrait être
reconnu responsable d'un accident de la
circulation la circulation de la route
et peut-être aussi circulation sanguine
on sait jamais le short est fait pour
porter sur les stades pour porter au
grand jour et où le voit-on voit la nuit
et dans les boîtes
il est fait pour l'accomplissement des
sport viril même s'ils sont accomplis
par les femmes et à quoi sert-il à gérer
plus aisément
alors il me donne un peu l'impression si
vous voulez de d'un chien de chasse dans
un salon mal adaptée si on vous dit que
la mode du short situe dans un large
mouvement de libération de la femme
qu'est ce que vous répondez non moi j'ai
plutôt l'impression que c'est le
contraire moi je trouve que de short
puis l'absence de soutien gorge et tous
ceux qui expriment pas pour moi du tout
la libération de la femme ça exprime
plutôt le contraire
oui puisque ça exprime une certaine
féminité un désir de plaire à l'homme
donc une certaine servilité au contraire
[Musique]
hiddink
petit hic
[Musique]
le champ notamment parce que c'est le
printemps
donc il fait beau le long avait main les
jambes quand on monte dans la voiture
qui se prenait là dedans et puis donc
ses cours on est aéré mais c'est
beaucoup plus décentes la minijupe même
pour les petites filles oui elles sont
ravies de se traîner juste le collant à
laver puis c'est tout c'est beaucoup
plus pratique bretelles pour ou contre
le short contre le short
moi je les très jolies cuisses et l'ont
emporté par nom mais pas son bureau je
pense que ce mauvais effet d'ailleurs
notre patron de la cnil a posé la
question
s'il est un chargeur est aussi en charge
dans cet établissement où est ce que
nous sommes et langil à 104 ont une
quarantaine d'années dans les traits
danger springs est venu en bretagne cet
hiver mais une body shop
non peut-être shorts et bermudas enfin
shop un peu indécent
[Musique]
dit
iam est bonne
trois de ces ridicules d'accord
d'ailleurs il ya qu'à voir la réflexion
des gens qu'est ce qu'ils disent les
gens font du célé il a des poils
enfin moi je suis content parce que ça
fait prendre un peu d'oxygène
[Musique]